this is a little weird i have to say it
i don't tend to think of myself as
somebody who keynotes
renowned technical conferences like this
so i'm still kind of adjusting and
getting used to everything so stick with
me
um it's it's just a a weird thing they
said
alex um and all the other wonderful
organizers like i we wanted you to come
in and talk about this
stuff that you do and i was like hey
sure i can do that
and it's like oh now i need to figure
out what it is that i do exactly because
i don't know if i i didn't conceptualize
it like i set out to do these things and
that's what i'm known for
it's just kind of stuff that i do and so
people want me to talk about it which is
awesome
but i have to kind of think about what
is it that i do
and how do i want to communicate what i
do and all that
and i could just take the the simple
route
and just be like well i do these things
um i'm a kind of a designer
developy type person i do a lot of work
in a diversity arena
about diversity and technology things
like that and i could just come up and
say
hey i have i've done these things these
are sort of the things that i've
i've done um but i thought that that
really wasn't all that
exciting like i wanted to talk a little
bit more about
like why i'm doing things and especially
when it comes
to diversity right because this is a
question that comes up a lot
in this field it's come up often maybe
almost every day at this point
um so if i'm going to come talk about
this question
what am i doing in diversity what am i
doing in this field what am i doing in
education
i think it's not enough just to answer
these simple questions of doing this or
that
it's more of starting this discussion
and creating this context
for having the discussion in the first
place um why are we doing this how does
it fit into our field as a whole
how can we improve all of that so i'm
going to tackle that and we'll see how
it goes
so i know that you guys have been all
day here you've been
listening to some amazingly smart people
all of them talking about how we can
take our knowledge and understanding of
programming and push it ahead
and so now i kind of want to talk about
what that all means but
where i'm coming from to answer the
simple questions first
i'm jen i work by day at a place called
dev boot camp
which uh in chicago there's one in san
francisco as well
we're a accelerated ruby on rails
training program so
we have beginners come in and then we
turn them into
world-class beginners so they have a
little bit more knowledge and they can
go out the door
and our know how to learn that's
essentially the goal of that you can't
make anybody a master
a software developer in nine weeks and
we're not really interested in it but
we're interested
in taking people and teaching them how
to learn
and get comfortable with that process of
learning and growing
and send them out in the world to do
that the other thing that i do a lot of
is
i'm involved with an organization called
girl development
i actually in 2011 i founded the
columbus ohio chapter of that if you're
not familiar with girl develop it it's a
now it's a national international
organization i think
of chapters in different cities and they
provide introductory programming classes
aimed at women
um it's it's more of a grassroots thing
it's just been kind of emerging there
so i've been kind of shifted into most
of the work that i'm doing or is in this
education realm and this diversity realm
um kind of this meta realm
of thinking about how are we you know
communicating
and teaching programming and how are we
communicating with the public about
what's what this
is the software that we're making what
does it even mean
so that's you know there's a high level
of what i do when on
the the lower level it's also i don't
know if i consider myself an expert in
any of that stuff i don't know if i
consider myself an expert in anything
if i'm good at anything it's like it is
being a beginner
um so i've been around the tech industry
for about a decade i think
it's hard to keep track i've done a
little bit of everything i've
studied computer science i've worked in
technical support
like i said before most of my career has
been spent as a web designer
and then now i'm doing educational
things so i kind of have this mixed bag
of experiences and i feel like the only
thing i'm really good at
is is learning and beginning and jumping
into things
but actually and kind of into that um
but i also say that to
make clear that i'm not giving this talk
or
any of the things i'm going to talk
about today it's not so much that i'm a
seasoned general and i'm
debriefing you on all these winning
strategies i don't necessarily have
those
i feel much more like i'm writing you a
letter from the trenches
and this is just what i'm seeing and
i don't really have answers i don't even
know exactly how i feel about a lot of
this stuff and
honestly right now i feel pretty
uncertain i feel a little scared
so i'm just the best i can do is say
this is what i'm seeing this is what i
know for me and i'm going to try to put
that in some sort of a context in the
way it makes sense to me and hopefully
that will connect with you and it will
give us this context to have a larger
dialogue
so as i said before most of my career
has been spent in design
i'm really really fascinated by the
concept of interfaces in general
both in a very specific like software
context
and just in general what an interface is
what it means
i love the idea of of intersections of
these
these places where there's potential for
action
and in software specifically we have we
have lots of interfaces and
that's where users come in to actually
use the things that we make
and there's lots of really fascinating
stuff around that for which is why
i've been drawn to making those things i
really like the idea of being able to
understand enough about both sides the
software side the user side
and creating a bridge so that people
create use it most effectively
and thinking about interfaces and why i
like interfaces
and all of that stuff i started thinking
about
um you know what that process is like so
i had an experience once
in a few years ago in a work project i
was working on
and we had this just massive
system that we were working with i think
it was academic based something along
those lines
and they had come a client had come to
us and they're like you need to do
something with this because we don't we
don't know
and our team was working on you know
building a new system for them and it
was just
it was really difficult to deal with all
of this
old code that was there um to figuring
out
what they wanted terminologies all these
different things
um this is an actual rendition of what
code looks
spidey code looks like um and that's
kind of system we were in
it was really difficult to figure out
how what my job was with this
i just felt like there's this huge
overwhelming system that we have to deal
with we just
it was just handed to us and we're
supposed to make it better
um but it's hard to even know what to
where to start
or what to start doing i don't even know
how do i even understand what this is
um and i actually did when i was working
on this the tasks i was supposed to do i
i felt really overwhelmed i felt really
i don't know where i don't even know how
to understand this i can't
get information from the clients to
understand what they need to use it for
i look try to look under the hood and
look at the code and try to figure out
what's doing what and what's connecting
to what
and i'm just completely confused and
overwhelmed um
and that and then at some point it just
all of a sudden i just realized like i
don't have to
rebuild everything or redesign
everything all at once as a team we
weren't rebuilding it
all at once i could take a little piece
that i had access to that didn't make
sense to me
and maybe i can create a new way for the
users to interface with that to work
with that
um and i did that and when i did that i
realized that we had clarified
some some goals and some functionalities
that we had we
clarified something at least and from
there
then we could you know start a longer
discussion with the clients i could
have a more productive discussion with a
developer as i was working with
and then we could start that kind of
build on top of that
so i realized that i don't have to do
all this all at once if i'm faced with
this system that i don't quite
understand or i want to improve but i
don't know what to do with
i can just pick a piece and create a new
way for people to interact with it
and we can build off that from there and
hopefully we can build a whole new
better system from that
and so i learned that and i also learned
that there are lots of systems
and there are lots of interfaces and
there are a lot of systems that are
misunderstood and a lot of interfaces
that are
not optimized when i was navigating a
lot of the cultural waters in the
technology field
that were challenging to me i realized i
was very
much of the same type of place where we
have this huge sprawling system
there's lots of history there there's
lots of things that work well now
um but there is difficulty for some
people to connect with all of that
there's difficulty in explaining that um
we look at this
and we see certain things like there's a
gender imbalance there's a racial
imbalance there's a class imbalance
there's even just
in general the sense of the public
doesn't really understand what we do
when we make software right it's a very
mysterious black box thing
so there's a lot of things around there
that aren't quite connecting
or it reminded me of this code base that
i used to work in that was
just so overwhelming that i didn't know
what to do with it
but if i could take a piece of this
culture
that that i have access to that i have
control over and create a different way
for people to interact with it
maybe we can start something and make
everything a little bit better
so i started applying that type of
thinking to what i wanted to see
in a society level or you know within
this industry level with people
and what we're doing with education and
minor regroups and all of that type of
thing
i try to approach it in this idea of
creating a new type of interface
um so like the first thing when we're
creating
an interface though when i was like
working i'm actually working in a
technical sense
one of the first things i do is we have
to understand what we're dealing with in
the first place
so i have a few things that i'm going to
throw out here that describes what we're
going for and these are just a grab bag
of stuff so
let's just go through them this is the
first one
the funny thing is i said earlier that
this question pops up a lot
it pops up so often that i actually was
able to replace this article
because it just came out last week or
week before it's september
12th um and i actually had a different
one in here and then all of a sudden
this popped up i'm like well i can use
that
um that's how often this more
information and things come up here
this is a story in the atlantic a little
bit of a
head attention-grabbing title that we
don't need to spend too much time on but
the basic point of this is there's a new
report that came out from the u.s census
um again just this month in september
2003
describing the trends in stem fields and
education
for women and other minorities and
basically the biggest point out of this
which you see in the sub headline there
is that women's participation in stem
in the computing fields specifically
have been declining since 1990
and also includes the young women are
the growth of young women coming into
computing fields
is not growing very much so
this is what actually comes out of the
census report
i will when i post slides i have links
to all the different uh
studies and things i'm referencing also
if you're
really really interested in educating
about the current landscape
all of those articles that i'm
referencing they also have this
wonderful thing called
comment sections and they are fantastic
minds of
information about discovering what the
current landscape is or if you just
really want to hate yourself
either one you can go check out the com
every article that i'm posting here has
hundreds of comments so you can just
imagine how much fun that is
um but you know this is the whole idea
let's gather data let's get a sense of
what this landscape is like
and the sensor report that just came out
this month these were listed literally i
took these verbatim from the highlights
of the report
and just really quickly to read off some
of those are so basically
women's representation and computer
occupations has declined since 1990s
nearly one in female science and
engineering graduates are out of the
workforce
the most recent decades show that the
growth in stem employment for young
women
is slowing and just to throw this up to
you that blacks and hispanics are still
very underrepresented in stem
that hasn't changed that's just there
and i think it's kind of important to
put that up there most of the stuff that
i'm going to talk about um
in this section of kind of gathering
data and understanding our landscape
is based on gender we don't even really
have resource for a lot of the other
areas
that aren't based on gender which is
kind of a commentary all in itself
but it's important to kind of make a
note of that
so this is another thing that came out
fairly recently i think this is in the
last year
as i said i'm just going to throw out
some studies that we have and see if we
can draw some
parallels at the end so we'll go through
a few of them this
is test scores for science tests that
were given to
grade school girls um and boys in
countries all over the world
um it turns out in every well 65
countries
other than the u.s girls actually
outperformed boys
in the u.s it was dramatically the
opposite
this is interesting just to say that
there's some
looks like there's some cultural
imbalances and depending on where you
are and what kind of society you're in
we get different results in terms of
expressing aptitude
this is another study that was done and
i just i really like the title of this
apparently psychologists have senses of
humor too
they did a study where they gave a math
test to i think it was all college age
men and women
um told a certain portion of the women
that
they could use a fictitious name just
basically they're separating themselves
from the idea of who they are as their
selves
and then measured the performance on it
and every woman who used a fictitious
name
performed better on this math test even
if she used the name of like another
woman it wasn't even
this specifically gender thing it was
this idea if she could release herself
from the
expectations of whatever she thought she
had to
you know reach up to or live up to she
actually performed better
men had no difference whatsoever so
there's it seems like there's some
strange ideas of we have women have in
their heads of what they need to live up
to and if they
um that impacts their ability to do
certain things especially in math fields
there's a very similar
study that was done fairly recently and
this was for college students in physics
classes
and instead of separating from the idea
themselves they actually
kind of did the opposite and they asked
people to reaffirm themselves
and they had a portion of the exam that
was to describe their values
and it was it was going to be like a
graded portion so it had equal weight
and then the rest of this was some
standard physics stuff
and what happened is that the women who
were given a space to talk about their
values and essentially yeah reaffirm
themselves
close the gap in between men and women
and their performance on the physics
side
whereas in the control group when that
didn't happen the women
were far below the men in terms of that
and again with the men no matter what
they did
it was pretty much across the board
this is another study that came out
these will end soon don't worry i'm just
making a point
um this is specifically a psychological
study about
the and i think this was a lot of tech
job descriptions they took a study of
all these different descriptions
um found different words and adjectives
that were used for jobs that were
typically
geared towards women such as secretarial
jobs things of that nature
and then got jobs that were geared
towards men um and it's nothing even
like like it's
it's nothing obvious it's not like they
called everybody programmers and that's
why the women didn't want to apply
although that does happen right this was
much more subtle this is just
words that we don't even think about is
typically masculine or feminine but
kind of unconsciously as a society we've
learned to associate with one gender or
the other
and those will pop up in job
descriptions um and the study actually
says that they think this
will continue that work workplace and
balance and through things like this
this is one of my most favorite piece of
research
pieces of research that i turned up in
this a
researcher did a study of many
transgender men
in the workplace this is not
specifically tech but just in the
working world in general
and recorded their experiences and how
many transgender men what their
experiences were like working as a woman
there and then coming back to the same
place and working as a man
and it is fascinating there's this
anecdote right there if you see in there
where
um there's literally a man named thomas
and he transitioned on the workplace and
came back
as susan and somebody else in an
associate company actually told the
supervisor
it's like hey getting rid of susan that
was a good move this thomas guy was
really great and
and it's what's even more interesting in
this study though is that they were
companies that were aware of their
transition and they were still treated
differently
because even when they were aware of it
there was so much kind of cultural bias
and differences in how you would treat
one gender or another
that even they were perfectly aware this
is literally the same individual
and when they presented differently they
were treated differently
so that's just a sampling of all this
other stuff
so i'm going to tie it together with a
quote i really love by a woman named
sally ride
and when she was asked about these
imbalances that we see
specifically in the science field or the
space
program where she was involved somebody
asked her that specifically
what is it is a woman just aren't
interested is there a biological
difference what's going on
and this was her response she said
suppose you came across a woman
lying on the street with an elephant on
her chest you notice she's short of
breath
shortness of breath can be a symptom of
her problems
in her case the much more likely cause
is the elephant on her chest
for a long time society put obstacles in
the way of women who wanted to enter the
sciences
that is the elephant until the playing
field has been leveled and lingering
stereotypes are gone
you can't even ask the question
so i think she really does sum up what i
think about all of this
is that i think that there are some we
have a lot of data
that points to some clear psychological
stereotypes that have grown through our
culture and that come out in our
behavior that a lot of times we're not
even aware of
um and if we want to talk about any kind
of
you know why aren't more women doing
this are they not interested or
what do we need to do to fix this we
really need to look at all these kind of
almost and a lot of times unconscious
barriers that are there
instead of attributing to other things
that are far less likely we'll get to
those down the road but first let's take
care of the
things that we have data on that we are
seeing right in front of us and see what
we can do with that
so it took me a really long time to
start thinking about all this stuff
um i attended 10 or so years ago maybe a
little bit longer
i had started teaching myself html and i
thought it was really cool to put stuff
in the computer and make it do things
and i never had experience like that
because i grew up in rural working class
ohio and i was very artsy
so i didn't have access to a computer
and i
wasn't really thinking that i could do
anything like that so when i finally
found that stuff it was really cool and
so i immediately decided i was going to
go learn computer science because it was
that simple right
and so i went to to a computer science
program in a small school in ohio
and it kind of sucked it was not a good
experience
it was really demoralizing i was the
only female computer science major in my
entire school
on my entire class there was one more in
the school she was a year beyond me and
that was it
most of my classes were me and a bunch
of dudes who didn't want to talk to me
um they were very nice they just didn't
want to talk to me um
and it was just really difficult for
somebody who is coming from an outside
perspective i'm a very visual person too
so this stuff
is definitely not things that comes to
me naturally i'm very interested in it
but i have to
really think about it and work at it and
approach it from different directions
um it was really hard for me in that
in that environment and i i made it
through it kept going through and
you know we're over three years down the
road and i was getting by but i was just
getting really frustrated i felt super
isolated
and in that spence in that experience
right there i went to
um oh i spent a summer working as a tech
counselor in a kids tech camp
it was super fun it was hosted at
carnegie mellon which is a really great
computer science school
um and so i also got access to some of
the other counselors who
went to carnegie mellon and there was a
woman in particular who taught the older
kids
some programming c plus plus and she was
a computer science major at carnegie
mellon and i found someplace
sitting down and i was telling her my
experiences and at the time i was
talking to her i had pretty much come to
the conclusion
that i just could not do this that was
that was the only logical conclusion
that i just wasn't smart enough my mind
just didn't work that way
and that even though i was kind of
making through these classes and i was
still really interested in being able to
make things
that i just wasn't good enough to do it
and that was basically the conclusion i
had come to
um and it was really interesting because
i was telling her all these things and i
was telling her that i just feel like
everybody else already knows this stuff
and i feel like i can't ask questions
and because then they'll think oh well
she doesn't know that she doesn't belong
here all of this type of stuff
and i'll never forget she said to me she
says i feel exactly the same way
and it totally blew my mind because she
had all the other advantages that i
didn't have she was naturally really
good at programming
her one of her parents was a math
professor she was at carnegie
mellon in the computer science program
there's like you obviously know what
you're doing
so why do you feel the same way i do
when i because the reason i feel the way
i do is because i don't know what i'm
doing
um and she said that and all of a sudden
it made me question
uh maybe there's something else out
there that i'm not aware of
maybe that does anybody else feel this
way and she suggested this book to me
it's called unlocking the clubhouse and
a couple of us psychologists at carnegie
mellon
just coincidence decided to study all of
this stuff and they published this book
about
12 13 years ago she suggested i read
this
i read this and again it was another
mind-blowing experience where there's
not only all this data but all this
anecdotes that i remember just going
through the pages
and all of these stories of women saying
the exact same thing
i was saying thinking and feeling and
they were women who had different
backgrounds just like
me and this other woman that i compared
myself to like but you know you're
you're perfect you have all these things
i don't and that's what the problem is
you know no that wouldn't be the case
there was a variety of women who had
a variety of different backgrounds and
experience and aptitude levels
and the only common thing that they had
was that they were women
and they were having the same
experiences
and that made me think that okay maybe
there's something else going on here
um at the time though i didn't do
anything i couldn't do anything about it
because i that's also i ended up having
my daughter and then i was a little busy
for a few years
um and i kind of i was doing web design
and i t work but i wasn't really focused
on learning new new things for a number
of years
i was a single mom too so like when i
say a little busy i mean like i was
crazy horribly busy for years
um and then i got to a point maybe i
don't know
four years ago maybe five years ago
where
i realized i had been out of things for
a while and i realized that i had to
make a choice
whether i have to entirely give up on
tech and go to something
that i'm just good at or i'm going to
rededicate myself
to learning this and i'm really going to
attack it i'm just going to do it
and i decided the latter but i also
decided
that i didn't want to have the same
educational experience i had the first
time around
and that there was nothing else around
that was going to
that seemed to be better than that that
was easily accessible to me
so i just decided that i was going to
have to make something like that
in this in my little journey here is
essentially when i decided that
i'm going to have to make a new way for
me to interface with this industry
if i'm going to get the things out of it
that i need and that's essentially what
i did
so i started girl develop at columbus at
the time when i started
this girl develop it existed for maybe
about six months
it was started by two women in new york
in late 2010 i believe
and i had started thinking about
something like this an idea of a program
that would offer classes in an
environment that would be really
welcoming to people who felt like they
didn't belong
in other classes that were available um
at the time i was just gonna do my own
thing i heard they were doing their
thing i reached out to them i'm like can
i get some advice
and they're like sure it's like you want
to just do this and i'm like hey why not
let's do that
um so i just said hey we're going to do
this thing in columbus ohio where i
lived at the time
i got some support from the community
saw who was interested in teaching
classes
a local company gave us some space and
we just started doing classes
eventually i started doing the html
classes for us and
it just kind of snowballed um like i
said when i started girl develop
the girl development chapter in columbus
i guess there's somebody had done
something in sydney but at the time
there's really only
two official uh chapters in the in the
us
there are 17 chapters across the world
now and we have a waiting list of other
chapters that are
trying to get in and we're actually
trying to get our organization stuff
together to get them through the door
um one of them is st louis actually so
that's why we did an event or they they
put together an event i
hopefully can help them get an actual
chapter here started
but the interesting experience of going
through girl development i've learned a
lot and one of the biggest things i
learned
it is has absolutely nothing to do or
the numbers of women currently in the
industry
have absolutely nothing to do with lack
of interest they are very very
interested when you reach out to them
they're like yeah we want to do this we
want to do more of this we're going to
do as much of this as we can possibly
can
and that's a very exciting thing to see
the other thing that i really felt that
when we were doing these classes
it didn't have as much to do with gender
specifically as it did with just
a welcoming environment and some of the
things that i was just talking about
that i felt turned me off
that was exactly why i wanted to make
sure i wanted to fix those things in
this
so we're going to have a class and it is
going to be
totally okay to ask dumb questions we
encourage you to ask dumb questions
and we're going to support each other
we're not going to wonder like you mean
you don't you don't know that already
why don't you know that already
no that we're not doing any of that
we're going to support each other to
grow
and learn and that's going to be a
positive thing it's going to be a really
positive thing that we have the courage
to say hey i want to learn something new
and i'm going to put my self out of my
comfort zone to learn something new
but if i can do that in a supportive
environment it makes it that much easier
and it makes it that much easier to
continue to put myself out of my comfort
zone and learn if i've had a good start
and so that's what we really emphasize
with the classes
and we got a lot of really great
feedback for that so
i don't have data quite yet like i did
for some of the other things i had
earlier
of uh we don't have i don't have studies
i don't have a lot of numbers for you
yet we're still trying to work all that
stuff out
it's mainly this came from a lot of
people who were frustrated with the
available
available system and said we want to do
something different
and so we're going to create a new way
for people to interact with the system
to learn this material to learn
all this things that we love to do we're
going to find a way for them to get in
and do this
so we don't have a whole lot of data
personally i've had a lot of really
great experiences
really great feedback one of the last
students in the classes i taught in
columbus
i guess i didn't mention i now live in
chicago and so i am co-leading the girl
of
chicago chapter we haven't got any
classes
started or actually held them yet in
chicago i'm working on that
but in columbus one of the last classes
i taught i had a student who came in
and actually we we did like it was four
it's a four week course we finished the
first week
and at the end of class she said i was
really scared and anxious to come here
and now i feel really comfortable and i
feel really excited about learning all
this stuff
and i was like that's it that's what i
wanted to do i don't really have
you know these uh measurements of these
are the numbers of people who have done
this or that
but i have that woman and what she said
to me and
that is really really important to me so
for right now being able to focus
on that that one interaction um that
really granular level of somebody coming
in
and having that kind of an interaction
that's super important to me and that's
where my focus is right now
as we continue on with that hopefully we
will excuse me be able to gather more
data
get more numbers get some sense of what
we've actually done for people i do know
have a couple other anecdotes that
we have helped people switch careers um
we have
i'm very proud personally that another
student we had in columbus
is going to be in a couple weeks coming
to deb boot camp chicago to launch a
career as a software developer which is
really exciting to me
um so there's you know little bits are
happening it's not this huge
all of a sudden we've changed everything
and everything is great there's just
little interactions little bits
happening here and there
um and hopefully there's our gaming
momentum so
that's a really good good good thing to
think about when we were thinking about
this
this idea of an interface however
we don't want to just keep it at that
level if we're just
doing little things bit by bit and yeah
that's great and i really love having
those interactions with people
but eventually we want to make sure that
this is
what's going into the the mainstream
system
that these things are in sync i had a
lot harder describing what i want
to talk about for this because we don't
have this yet right
so and even what we're doing now is
we're in this middle stage now where
we're creating new interfaces we're
creating little inroads
we don't have a whole big thing here yet
so i was trying to think of some
examples of what would exemplify what i
would think if we had a new system if we
had people leading a new system
um that would you know be pulling people
in
be uh making it this idea of education
and software and education for people
who aren't in the
established tracks for it make that a
really kind of accessible thing
so i started pulling out some examples
of some people who are not doing this
necessarily in software but are doing it
in slightly
adjacent areas i have three examples and
they all have some of the theme that i
swear i didn't plan so it kind of came
out really weird
but hopefully this will be fun to talk
about one of them
we already had a preview of this is
sally ride
and she is one of my absolute heroines
ever
if you don't know who sally ride is that
makes me really sad
but just in case uh celery was the first
woman
american woman in space she also was
this
just really amazing person who after you
know she had her career at nasa
she became an advocate for stem
education and getting more minorities
into the space program and just stem
careers and
in general she started a foundation it's
called sally ride science
and she gave interviews she went to
school she created opportunities and
scholarships and all this amazing stuff
just to
get more people involved in this um
this is sally right science i meant to
go ahead with that this is a website
still up today unfortunately she died
last year of cancer
but up until then she was very heavily
involved her partner is still on the
board of this foundation
to be able to kind of make all that
stuff happen
this is another quote from her where it
says i never went into physics or the
astronaut core
to become a role model but after my
first flight it became clear to me that
i was one
and i'm beginning to understand the
importance of that to people young girls
need to see role models in whatever
careers they may choose
just so they can picture themselves
doing those jobs someday you can't be
what you can't see
well my favorite thing about her and why
i mean obviously yeah she's pretty
heroic and so you would see why people
would like her
but for me the big thing is that she was
not a person
who struggled with math or science or
any of this
uh stem education stuff that we're
talking about she wasn't like me
she came very naturally to all of this
but she also said at some point that she
realized that even though she had just
gone through
the other girls her age that she had
grown up around that she had been
educated with
were not so lucky and she said i don't
know why this is
maybe it was because they were
discouraged by an educator a teacher a
parent at some point along
but at some point she said all the girls
middle schoolish they just started
not caring about science they started
dropping out of their math classes or
you know putting effort into that and
they just didn't care about that
and the thing i love about sally ride is
that she did not look at that problem
and say like
oh well they just must not have been
good enough for it or they must not be
interested in that
she immediately said hey that happened
what can i do to help fix it
she immediately used her power and her
the ease that came to her
and what she had earned through that and
used that and leveraged that to be able
to make it easier for other people to
learn through education
and i think that is awesome and that's
one of the reasons that i really really
appreciate her example this is my other
favorite example
this i had a much more serious picture
of him before and then i found this one
i'm like no this has to go in the slide
deck
uh so if you don't know who this is this
is an astrophysicist named neil degrasse
tyson
there's a good chance you do know who he
is which is entirely the point of this
um he is very very visible he's a very
dedicated science advocate he's been on
the daily show he's been on the
colbert report a number of times he's
all over the media
and he does that deliberately as a
scientist
i think i've even said heard in
interviews with him before that he said
sometimes he'd rather just be in the
laboratory he'd rather
just be kind of doing science but he has
a talent for communication he has a
talent for speaking and he has a talent
for reaching people
and he has a passion for science
literacy and so he puts himself out
there
if you've never seen him speak or if you
ever have the opportunity to see him
speak even if you have already seen him
speak
go do that he's an amazing speaker
and the me the main thing about that
though it's not just that he knows what
he's talking about he does
but it's also this passion that he
brings to this idea of
of science and also understanding
science it's
really important to him that the public
understands science
not just because he likes it he wants to
push on everybody else
because he thinks it's a really powerful
tool for our society
this is a quote he gave to npr at one
point he said so
i think we're at an interesting paradox
access to science is greater than ever
before
yet you have people who believe they are
scientifically literate but in fact are
not
we're an elective democracy where
sciences technology will define
where the economically strong countries
in the world will be you can't have the
people making decisions about the future
of the world
who are scientifically illiterate
illiterate
you can replace all this stuff with just
straight up technology and you get the
same thing
i think this is true about the field
we're in i think it's
really really important that people have
and we don't all have to have the same
levels of understanding there's
different definitely
degrees but i think the public as a
whole should be much more
educated on technology it's not going
anywhere
it's a huge part of everybody's lives
and the more that we can make that
information accessible
the more we can build up an educated
populist who can make informed decisions
about some of this stuff
um so if i had to pick an example of
somebody that i feel is
we need somebody going out and doing
that for the software industry i want
like our neil degrasse tyson who's going
to put himself out there and he's going
to make it exciting
and interesting for people to learn
about these things so they can inform
themselves to make decisions in this
society we're moving into the future so
i have one more
this is a still kind of in the same
theme not quite as much
so this is this is this is kind of meta
this is lieutenant uhura from star trek
the original
1960 star trek series the actress who
played her was a woman called nichelle
nichols
michelle nichols is awesome if you don't
know anything about her you should go
look some
information up about her she she did a
lot of
really interesting things and it kind of
started there's a story that she tells
often
you may have heard this especially i
know it's kind of crazy there might be
some star trek fans here but i'm
guessing there might be one or two
um so she has the story she told and
so this is original star trek started in
1967 i believe so 67-68
she was in the show she was the only
black person
certainly the and the only one female
main character and this was at that time
period
i think she said in interviews that she
actually had people who
lived in the south in that time who were
not allowed to watch a show because the
show was integrated
it had the first interracial kiss ever
they got letters about that
crazy time and at some point she had
been on the show she enjoyed the show
but she wasn't getting as many
opportunities
and another opportunity on broadway had
come up and so she had decided to leave
the show
and it just so happened when she had
just made that decision she spent the
weekend
at a fundraiser like a naacp fundraiser
i think she says it is
and she was there one of the organizers
said hey there's somebody
really really wants to meet you this is
one of those stories that you feel like
almost can't be real but if you hear her
tell it you know it is real this
actually happened
so the fan that wanted to meet here was
martin luther king jr
and he said you star trek is the only
show that we let our kids watch
because it's it's great it has
you're there and we have this idea of
all these people who can work together
in this common cause on a basis of
science and technology and they progress
to that point
and so they were talking at some point
and shell said something on the lines of
you know i'm really going to miss the
people i'm with and
she said dr king's spacious and me that
was like what are you talking about
and she said i'm i'm going to leave the
show and he said you can't do that
so you can't you can't do that
she says that's literally what
apparently from according to her he said
you can't do that he said do you know
what it's like to have you on that show
for people to see you it's that you
being there
tells everybody that it doesn't end here
that there's something else
that we can work towards that's farther
down the path that's better
and that it's worth everything we're
going through now because maybe we can
get to something like that
and she said on the show i guess after
that experience you would kind of have
to but
she she got it and she did stay on star
trek so
after she was done with that she spent
18 years working for nasa as a recruiter
and she went around to
university she went around to school she
went around anywhere where
there might be people who are interested
in math and science and technology
and she recruited and she brought
basically what she did is she brought
nasa this whole pool of diverse people
and say here
choose your astronauts from this pool
and they did and that's how she
was able to pull in uh the first
african-american astronauts she was able
to pull in more women that they had ever
had before
and they became part of the the pool of
qualified people that nasa could choose
people for their program from um the
first african
woman in space mae jemison uh cited you
her as her inspiration for becoming an
astronaut
and she actually did a guest spot on
star trek the next generation
because she said that was why she became
an astronaut
so i really love the fact that michelle
nichols took so much of her life and she
took that role seriously
when it was pointed out to her how
important that visibility was
to have this vision of what could be
and then to see in the real world
that actually did inspire people to do
great things and it actually made
actual change in in this other industry
that she wasn't even a part of she was
an actress this was
this isn't it real sorry to break it to
you but star trek wasn't real
but her influence well that's debatable
but you know her influence and her
visibility it literally created
his you know historical astronauts
people
you know who broke you made history
because they had that example to look
from i think there's
extremely powerful and really really
awesome
the thing is though um sorry we don't
want that quite yet so let's keep
talking about this um
these all examples they have to do with
science and technology and some of the
things i'm talking about
they don't have anything to do with what
we are doing right here right
as i you know i do a lot of talking
about these topics
and um i do interviews things like that
um
i remember i did an interview on for a
tv station in chicago when we were
starting to boot camp
and they asked me a lot of things about
the number of women in the program and
all this other things about learning
about what it was like to to make
applications to be
a programmer what was that all about and
the last question they asked me was like
what do you think about the social
network
the movie right that was the
fictionalized account of mark zuckerberg
making facebook
which if you haven't seen that is not a
positive depiction of a programmer
um it's basically the citizen gain of
programmer movies um but the thing is
that's people's touch points that's not
the first time i've been asked an
interview about the social network
it happens a lot and not only does that
happen i have actually literally had
young people they've all been all been
guys
among people who are interested in being
programmers who reference
that character in that movie as an ideal
that they want to be
and when i try to gently ask about this
it's just kind of like well
but he's so smart so it doesn't matter
how he acts
so there's this sense of we have and you
know what but that fits into the
programmer stereotype really all right
i mean the stereotype exists out there
and it does all of us a disservice
because it's a very one-dimensional
kind of kind of an [ __ ] character
essentially
of somebody who is really really smart
in some areas
um and that gets him a free pass from
growing in other areas
and i find that really really sad you
know human growth is not a zero-sum game
it doesn't mean because you have to
stunt your growth in some areas so you
can be really awesome in other areas in
fact it's usually the reverse
so if we could encourage people to you
know grow as human beings
and learn how to embrace the process of
growing and embrace the process
of learning it actually might be better
programmers too
but we have this you know this ideal
that exists we don't
we don't have a uhura we don't have
somebody like that we have
uh mark zuckerberg and the social
network who is
like worse than the real mark zuckerberg
i keep saying that name because that's
the connotation obviously but i'm sure
he's a much nicer guy than the guy in
the movie but
we know the guy in the movie like that's
our our touchstone
and that's really disappointing and
depressing to me like i said i think
that's selling us all short
this is a quote that i really really
love it's not by a scientist or anybody
like that this is by ray bradbury
um this is actually a quote taken from a
panel
that was 1970 right before
oh i can't remember the name of it one
of the satellites
we had just sent was going to reach mars
and the eve of that
they hosted a special panel where they
got arthur c clarke carl sagan
and ray bradbury together because there
was a time where you could just do that
because it was that awesome at some
point
um and they talked about all of this
stuff
about science and education and what we
know and what we don't know and this was
a time where people were really
excited about space exploration um and
that was in
you know that was driving research that
was driving discovery that was driving
some really amazing things to happen
but it was kind of rooted in the fact
that people wanted it or you know they
wanted to see it happen
and this is what ray bradbury had to say
about a lot of that
so i think it's part of the nature and
man to start with romance and build to a
reality
there's hardly a scientist or astronaut
i've met who wasn't beholden to some
romantic before him who led him to doing
something in life
i think it's so important to be excited
about life
in order to get the facts we have to be
excited to go out and get them
and there's only one way to do that
through romance we need this thing which
makes us sit bold upright when we are 9
or 10 and say
i want to go out and devour the world i
want to do these things
i think that when we talk a lot about
education or diversity or
all these things i've been talking about
i think that they're it's all the same
thing in the end we talk about that in
this field that we're in here and when
it comes to making software
i feel like a lot of times we have a
resistance to it because we don't want
to
dilute anything we don't want to dumb
anything down
we want it to be really hardcore and
technical and that's awesome i respect
the impulse
but i think that it's also good to frame
it in this context is that
this inspiration this example that we
can have
can get that path started and that also
that might be able to drive things even
further than we would have been able to
take them otherwise
there's a lot of stuff going on in this
context so we have
an interface we have a system i'm trying
to figure out
ways that we can get people to interact
with our system that will make the
system better
and basically when it comes down to is
this idea of
it's not about diluting or dumbing
anything down or making things
accessible
by putting them on a lower level it's
about investing our time and effort
to elevate other people we should be
doing that it should be we should take
that as a responsibility on ourselves
that
we really love and care about what we're
doing we care about our system we care
about our product we care about
these things that we're learning and
that we spend all our time trying to
make better we really care about that
then instead of saying well if you don't
really have it at the same level we do
or you don't care about the same level
we do
so we're just we're not going to
interact with that let's run the other
direction
and be like let's see if i can we can
bring you up to this level let's elevate
you
let's create examples um and heroines
and heroes and people that we can look
up to
that inspire and bring that romance and
that passion into it
and so we can continue on in that track
to bring more people in there
and i'd like i said i think we can go
even farther than we would if we didn't
have that in there
it's not necessarily about changing
every anything that we have
now it's about creating new ways to do
it and just building on top of that
and it's also about challenging
ourselves like i was saying with this
example of
the programmer that we have where maybe
in some ways
they don't they aren't always growing as
much as they could be
we all can challenge ourselves to make
sure
that we're growing and learning as much
as we possibly can
do we have things that we're not
questioning do we have biases we're not
questioning do we have things that we've
never really thought about before
that maybe we don't even realize it but
there are barriers to us growing or
learning something new
let's challenge those and we can
challenge them for the people around us
too or maybe some things that we've
always taken for granted that that is
just the way it is
maybe that's actually just a big old
wall there and we don't even realize it
and there might be something
beyond it that would be really amazing
and we just don't know because we
haven't questioned it
so this whole process of education and
reaching out to people who are already
in the field to me
is this process of challenging ourselves
to be better people so that we can make
better things because essentially that's
what it is at the end for me
and that's you know that's my system
that's what i want to do so i came in
saying i'm not really sure how to
describe
what i do and i guess i did a little bit
too but it's more important about why
i'm doing this
and essentially that's why i'm doing
this
i want i'm really excited about being a
part of this field i like to create the
things that i create
and i'm really excited about learning
what i'm learning and being able to
learn more about that it's been a long
road for me
but i really really like it it excites
me
and i like i like doing it for myself i
like doing it on that granular level
i like doing it on a level where i get
to see people who who use the things
that i make
i get to see like really amazing real
world
consequences and um and accomplishments
through software and that's that's
extremely exciting why don't we talk
about how exciting that is to other
people who don't know about it
why don't we work to bring other people
in so they can be excited with us
let's clear away the barriers and let's
bring it and just share all that we can
have a big party about it
but i think that if we can we can't do
it all right away right
um so we don't want to get overwhelmed
to be and be like well we've got to
change everything we don't need to
change everything some of it's good
some of it that's not so good we can
create ways to bring more people in and
get more help and work together to make
it better
and once we've made everything better
then we'll all feel
you know that we can accomplish more on
an individual or a bigger level
so in the end that's what that's what
i'm doing and i'm going to
try to keep doing that as long as i can
and you know hopefully
at some point we will have a system in
place where we don't even really need to
talk about all this stuff anymore
we'll just be out there doing it and
we'll all be out there making great
things
and that's what i hope we can get to
someday and that's what i've got so
thank you
i can do questions does anybody have
questions
okay i can't see anything
okay maybe i can see you all right go
for it
you're welcome
and we put on some classes and we can't
get people to you know kind of attend
them
and um i i have been following
what's been going on a little bit you
know with a lot of the i guess the
chatter about
um diversity it's kind of picked up
lately and um
occasionally there's a resistance to men
helping
you know i think sometimes in some
environments that's like that um
what would you suggest to those of us
that are in approvals
in a privileged position you know i just
find myself saying
how can i help i want to do something
about it
and most of the people in the room are
solution driven
you know we see a problem and so we
oversimplify it and we
use logic which doesn't really work
great so in this context
you know what would be that thing that
you would recommend is it just
go grab somebody and say you need to
come learn this
okay so yeah okay that's a great
question the question is
so i'm basically do you mind if i
paraphrase a little bit
so i'm a big paraphraser yeah
um so i'm a white dude i want to help
how do i do that effectively
um first of all that's awesome and thank
you and i know that
there's lots of people like that um my
own personal and this does
it is complicated especially if you
don't have a lot of
you know you want to do something but
you it's hard to get something started
from my own personal experience i very
much have always welcomed
men to actually help out with the
classes that i'm doing um
sometimes because i don't have any other
teachers an interesting thing
for me that i didn't really anticipate
when i started girl develop it is that
um i i was all focused on how we would
have to encourage uh the students cause
that's what it's there for right
i forgot that a lot of times you have to
encourage the teachers
i had so many women who would be like
hey this is awesome i really want to
help but i don't want to teach
because i i can't do that um it's the
same problem
and that makes sense in retrospect so um
so a lot of times i would have men come
in
to teach and it would just be a matter
of making sure they're really clear of
the context and understanding what was
important
like like i said before it wasn't so
much about the women thing it was more
about the environment thing and
understanding
uh how to be comfortable it's like you
don't have to be a woman to understand
that because it goes beyond that we just
happen to use that as an intersect point
the real diversity is underneath
this is not answering your question but
i'm just kind of setting the context so
what can you actually do sometimes you
can't do anything
you really do kind of have to make sure
that it's the right place and time
and i really like the fact that you did
you say like well how can i help and i
think that's kind of the best way to go
about it
is um sometimes there isn't a whole lot
you can do but just
kind of be a good person and honestly i
mean this goes for everybody there's a
lot of times i've been i've been doing
and talking about these issues for a
long time
i i tend to sometimes it's tiring
especially with a lot of the other stuff
going on and i got to a point where i
realized as well that
i can't change everything i can't do
anything this is where the interface
metaphor comes into play right where you
can't
you may not be able to solve this
problem and you said i know it's
frustrating we're problem solvers we see
a problem we want to go solve it
i'm exactly the same way it's why i've
done a lot of this stuff it's kind of
is like well that's wrong so i'm gonna
fix it
um and sometimes i realize like you just
you just can't do that
um but you could maybe find another way
to interface with the problem so
an example you had mentioned that you're
in a small town there actually just
aren't that many
that many women around or other people
around who want to learn this thing
um go online see if you can mentor
online
um there's lots of people who and maybe
this is something that the system
doesn't exist and you might have to
create it
i think it's awesome like i said i work
at a place where we're producing
beginners all the time to go out into
the world and one of the things that we
tell them is really really important is
learn the community learn about open
source contribute to projects
get into that mindset of doing things so
um being able to maybe like be a
connector for people like that and be
like hey are you
can i help anybody uh you know make
their first pull request
because i could i could walk you through
that it's kind of scary i know right you
don't know what people are going to say
i can do that i since i've been doing a
lot of speaking i started offering
speaker mentoring on just i just threw
this out on twitter be like hey
do you want to submit a talk but you
don't really know
how to think about it or practice or how
to write an abstract or anything like
that
just let me know and i started doing
skype calls with people for half hour
and just
kind of walk them through all those
steps and it's pretty awesome
to see that stuff happening so maybe you
just need to find a way to
put out ways that you can uh you can
help and have people
you basically have to have people come
to you and do that so i would say in
general i really
appreciate people who want to be allies
and want to help all those things
and i think the best thing to do is to
make sure that you're doing a lot of
listening
and you're a lot of offering that isn't
creating extra obligation
um and you know if you want but i would
say also that if you want any advice on
doing specific things like that but
you know don't be afraid to ask those of
us who are out there trying to do things
because chances are we need help
and we can use all of it that we can get
does that help
very much okay you're welcome any other
questions i can see some of you know i
see you
oh okay go ahead
um interesting they're very different so
i
i don't know if i feel comfortable
comparing to you i'm sorry the question
was
uh retention for programs like girl
develop as opposed to dead boot camp
for girl development retention is a
little bit of a bigger challenge because
most people are doing this in the
evenings around a job or a family or
something like that and so
some of them are just there to learn
something new um not all of them are
there to make a huge commitment to
try a new career even though i said
we've had a couple of those that's not
always
how it goes to be something like debt
boot camp is a huge commitment you give
up your life it's we call it a boot camp
for a reason
you give up your life for at least nine
weeks
um and the idea of that is yes i am
making a huge life change
uh so it's a different thing um
we have definitely seen in deb boot camp
the numbers of women have been steadily
rising as we go along
the cohort that we just started last
last monday had more women than anything
any other since we started in april
which is very good those numbers are
steadily rising
other than that it's really hard to make
comparisons between the two i think
retention in general in these
educational programs
if um you create the right atmosphere
we've definitely had women
who come back to different girl
development classes we've definitely had
women who maybe got what they needed out
of it but referred other people to it
so we don't see very many women who take
a class and then
just disappear like i i hate this you
know like it turns out i didn't really
want that that doesn't happen
i don't know if i've ever seen that
happen or if it has it's been so quiet
i've never noticed it
um usually we do see women come back um
and so far in both the educational
programs that i've been working
on we see them at least sticking with it
or
paying it forward to somebody else or
bringing somebody else in something
along those lines
is that it that's it thank you